six five zero area code identify
yourself please and tell me what's on
your mind today
my name is Aaron I'm the [ __ ] and the
liberal that called him last time I was
talking about gun laws and all that okay
go ahead Aaron so I guess no one this is
the thing I noticed the follow this was
like auntie Gotti liberals more like
which pile kolinsky and Chang cuter if
you're talking or is this is not
pertaining to you as much but if you
talk down to us and you don't know like
the gun laws for example we kind of just
automatically shut your opinion out it's
it's the view equivalent of a climate
change denier showing up to a climate
change rally and saying basically like
you're all basically just talking down
to them like I see so let me see what
Aaron let me see if I understand what
you're saying you're saying that when
anti-gun liberals argue about gun laws
but they don't even really know what the
laws are or or whatever that they sort
of they present themselves as not having
much credibility they sometimes they do
when you say Oh Dick's Sporting mm video
saying Dick's Sporting Goods sells
assault rifles that they're like they
stop selling them and Dick's Sporting
Goods I automatically thought oh wait
what did Dick's Sporting Goods sell
transferable machine guns oh I do don't
know the transferable machine gun is um
so there's there's so you don't even
know what the National Firearms Act in
1934 the oath relaxed 1968 or the Hughes
Amendment of the firearms owners
Protection Act is your IRA make a fair
point I think it's important to be
informed on issues you're going to
discuss but I do I you know I want to
mention a couple things that I think are
important to keep in mind like there was
a movement back during the Iraq war I
don't know how old you are but during
the second Iraq war in 2003 which
basically tried to disqualify the
opinion of anybody who had not served in
the military like if you weren't in the
military and you hadn't ever served in
the military
you basically have no right to comment
as to whether it's a good or bad idea to
go to Iraq like basically your opinion
matter logically fallacious doesn't
really make any sense another example of
that would be the idea that excuse me
Aaron if I if I just met here you you
you made it I'm just trying to make a
point here another example would be
during the battle around LGBT rights
there were people who were against LGBT
rights or gay marriage who said listen
you can't allow gay people to be part of
the conversation because they're biased
they're gay obviously they want gay
marriage it's a dumb argument right
because whether you are or aren't part
of the LGBT community that in either
case could affect your view on the issue
so I think if your point is merely that
it's good for people to be informed
about the issues they're there activists
for I agree with you if what you're
saying is something closer to you can't
comment on what the military should do
unless you've been in the military I
tend to disagree with you I think more
agree with you in the first part but
there's just some times where people are
just we need to ban assault rifles and I
automatically say oh they've been banned
since 1986 because they use and that
made bans you for making new machine gun
okay yeah listen I mean I thought that
there's a different reason that that's a
more relevant issue which is that most
gun deaths are not happening with rifles
period but I think I know the point
you're trying to make and and I do
appreciate the call I just don't know
not a hundred percent sure about you
know what my role sort of wasn't in
commenting on that let's take a quick
break if you're if you're holding please
don't hang up because we are going to
take more calls right after the break